y una tomografía computarizada tc
también conocida como tomografía axial
computarizada tc es una prueba
diagnóstica indolora que usa rayos xy
computadoras para crear imágenes
transversales de los huesos y los
tejidos dentro de su cuerpo su médico
puede recomendarle una te hace para
examinar su cuerpo en busca de lo
siguiente coágulos sanguíneos
huesos rotos
y tumores cancerosos
e infecciones
y lesiones y sangrado interno así como
signos de enfermedad cardíaca o vascular
una tomografía computarizada ayuda a su
médico a seleccionar la ubicación
correcta para la cirugía
biopsia o radioterapia verificar el
tratamiento para el cáncer o la
enfermedad cardiaca y revisar su
condición después de la cirugía un
escáner para tomografía computarizada es
una máquina grande de rayos x cuadrada o
redonda con un túnel por el centro
durante la tomografía computarizada
usted estará acostado sobre una mesa que
pasa lentamente a través del túnel a
medida que avanza el túnel un anillo
gigante llamado gantry o garganta
tubular girará alrededor de su cuerpo él
gantry contiene un tubo que libera a
cesc de rayos x y los detectores que
miden la cantidad de radiación absorbida
por su cuerpo a medida que el gantry
gira las haces de rayos x capturan
muchas pistas de su cuerpo desde
diferentes ángulos los detectores envían
los datos a la computadora la cual
creará las imágenes transversales de los
huesos y tejidos blandos dentro de su
cuerpo
el escáner le permite a su médico ver la
ubicación de la afección dentro de su
cuerpo lo que lo ayudará a decidir el
tratamiento a seguir
cómo está progresando su tratamiento en
algunos casos usted puede recibir un
medio de contraste antes del
procedimiento mediante una bebida una
inyección o un enema de bario para
facilitarle al médico la visualización
de ciertas zonas de su cuerpo si usted
ha tomado una bebida con medio de
contraste el esófago o el estómago
estarán resaltados
si usted ha recibido una inyección los
vasos sanguíneos la vesícula el hígado o
el tracto urinario estarán resaltados si
usted ha recibido un enema de bario su
intestino grueso estará resaltado
después del procedimiento usted puede
reanudar sus actividades normales si
recibió un medio de contraste ingiera
bastante líquido para ayudar a sus
riñones a eliminar dicho medio de su
cuerpo